♪ Persian ♪
♪ Persian electronic ♪
[music continues]
[music slowly fades]
There's plenty of dark stuff
that happens here
but there's a certain amount
of innocence in the culture.
And maybe that's why McDonald's
hasn't completely taken over the land.
I don't know what it is to be honest.
In a way it's refreshing.
There's some things that
are not refreshing here right now.
The situation can be felt.
But the way that people
have this authenticity.
I think that's a testament
to how special the culture is.
Mona took me to the skate park.
PETER: There's a woman
skateboarding scene here?
Yes.
You know, I like people who,
they express their inner-something.
You know, inner-self.
So there are lots of people
that are pretend living.
You know, they're living their life
in a way that they don't like to
but I respect people who just put
everything away, like money, everything.
Right.
They go around countries.
I really love to come to the level.
When you land a trick, (you) know,
you feel like you did a great job.
You did it.
You've done it, you know?
-It's over.
-Right.
And there are lots of bad (energies)
that go away from you
and the adrilany...
-Adrenaline?
-Adrenaline, yeah.
PETER: So Mona, we're in Tehran, right?
Yeah.
<Very cool park in here.
♪ Persian electronic ♪
And there was this woman, Negin.
She must have been maybe 17 years old.
PETER: So focused, so driven.
[skateboard clacking]
And she was out there in the skate park
trying this one trick on the rail.
She probably hit the ground
or the rail 35, 40 times.
♪ rock with distorted guitar ♪
[skateboard grinding and clacking]
[man speaking Persian]
PETER: Yeah!
[skateboard clacking]
That girl's tough.
She hit her head, she'd hit
her knees, her elbows, her wrists.
She'd get back up,
go at it again, go at it again.
Again, again, again...
[guitar intensifies]
PETER: Ooh!
[giggles]
Skating is a tough sport.
[skateboard slides and clacks]
[Mona sighs]
MONA: Yo.
-You need to give me a lesson.
-Yeah. [hands slap]
I haven't skateboarded
since I was like 14.
-How old are you?
-I'm 41.
MONA: 41... Young.
<You're young, so young.
So young, that's right, I like you.
[both chuckling]
And they said,
"We feel so free when we can skate."
♪ stand-up bass jazz ♪
PETER: So tell me about skateboarding,
what were you just saying?
It really feels good to skate in Iran
because we girls don't really have
a lot of freedom here in Iran.
Normal people don't accept
people who skate.
-Uh-huh.
-Especially skateboard.
PETER: And skating is, in my opinion,
it's like one of the hardest sports.
-If not the hardest sport.
-For sure.
The moment that you land (it),
it's everything.
It's everything?
-You feel adrenaline, satisfaction?
-It's awesome.
<You might be the toughest person
I've ever met in my life.
Thank you.
[all laughing]
One more and then I'm done.
I swear to God after this one I'm done.
Mona, I need one more picture.
These clouds and this light is perfect.
I'm gonna take them up here.
[giggling]
[cheering and laughing]
[hands slap]
-See you again.
-See you again, keep skating.
It's very expressive I would say.
This guy was doing quite an intense dance.
He's back at it again actually.
♪ hip hop ♪
♪ dub step ♪
[Mona laughing]
[hands slap]
I think Iranians are exceptional
at dividing politics and people.
A lot of people might hate US policy
but they don't hate American people.
I've been told that time and time again.
It's actually a very
pro-American country in that respect.
Zero animosity.
You can go to the US's closest
political ally, let's say the UK
and you'll get more animosity
than if you go to a foe politically.
And it's actually a good thing
to be American here.
It's so confusing.
♪ mellow guitar ♪
When you travel alone and you have
a country and a culture warm up
and come out and help
and offer you their phones
and help you in any way.
Invite you to their family's homes.
Invite you to dinners,
to sleep at their place.
Whatever it might be,
that's the goal of travel.
I want to say to the people of Iran
you have a special culture
and you're a special people.
It just gets the short end of the stick.
How their voices... How the beauty
of this country doesn't get out.
The human side of things
and so many people wanted to connect.
Purely... Authentically... Yeah.
I hope this captured some of that.
♪ guitar and harmonica ♪
[laughter]
[music fades]
♪ "Get Lucky" by Daft Punk ♪